foreign
hi Johnny welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey guys thanks for having me on sure
how can we help
so I um I'm a self-employed contractor
uh on 46 my wife's 40. we don't have
anything saved for retirement
um we have an auto loan a mortgage
a little bit of credit card debt and uh
and we're just wondering what the best
plan moving forward is from here we have
about 110 in savings
okay so how much debt do you have not
counting your house
uh I have a truck loan that's there's
about 40 left on it
and that's your only debt other than
your house
yeah a couple thousand in credit cards
but we usually pay that off for every
month and you have a hundred and ten
thousand in Savings in cash
correct not counting retirement
I have no retirement there's no 401
nothing how old are you
I'm 46 and my wife is 40 and she's uh
she stays home she's not in the hood all
right and what's your household income
sir
um it varies but I would say it's
probably around 90 to 100. good okay
all right Johnny I get the sense from
the words you're using and the way you
ask this question that you're fairly new
to this whole Ramsay discussion about
money
I am yeah okay all right
um so our whole thing is when I was in
my 20s I went completely broke because I
was stupid and I went into debt up to my
eyeballs buying real estate and that
taught me a lesson that stuck with me
the rest of my life I'm now 62 so I've
lived
35 years with zero debt
okay that's awesome and that has given
me the control of my most powerful
wealth building tool which is your
income
and it's easy to visualize this if you
had no payments
and you were in control of your money
with a written game plan where you're
telling every dollar what to do
you could enjoy life and also invest
aggressively and not be broke
because you make good money
that makes sense okay yeah absolutely
because your your car payment is is what
800. uh it's about 750 yeah almost like
I've done this before yeah okay yeah
right all right and so 750 and see if
you invest 750 a month from your age
until retirement you'll be a millionaire
that's awesome that's what I want yeah
you got 20 years
so you you'd be a millionaire and so but
but instead you got car payments
and no plan yeah no plan and you just
kind of wander along and go I got some
money saved but which you did a good job
110 000 in the bank you're way ahead of
most people right I mean that's pretty
impressive but but you kind of almost
you know it kind of almost fell into
that because it's not like you got some
detailed plan going I'm not picking on
you I just know you because I used to be
you is that okay
yeah that's that totally fine
understandable okay and so what we have
taught and what Sharon and I did after
we went broke is we got on a detailed
in-depth plan
and we became in charge of the money
making every dollar behave sometimes it
behaved for generosity sometimes it
behaved for investing sometimes it
behaves so we could have fun with it
all right okay and so then what we
discovered is again your most powerful
wealth building tool is your income so
if I woke up in your shoes what would I
do I would take some of the hundred and
ten thousand I pay off your card a day
okay
so my wife told me and then I would get
your credit cards out and I'd cut them
all up
we use one mainly and then we usually
pay it off at the end of the month you
know what if you use a debit card on
your checking account it does everything
your credit card will do and the money
comes straight out of your account so
you don't have to pay it off at the end
of the month it already came out
what about the cash back advantage that
we get like the points that we earned so
far it's not caused you to be rich
and by the way brother they're not your
friends so they're not hooking you up
with free money and flights every time
you use their card they're making their
money
you spend more money than you would
otherwise because you can just pay it
off later and it's psychological it's
just it's research in its data and it's
data in its data we don't tell you to
get rid of them because it's fun for us
we just look at the data man yeah so
when we talk when we talk to
Millionaires and we study researched
millionaires we find that they make
every dollar behave they're in agreement
with their spouse they quit borrowing
money and they invest and they're
generous and they pay off their house
and then they pay off their houses the
next thing so I'm gonna pay off I'm
gonna take 110 000 minus 40 which leaves
me 70. you make 90. so I'm gonna set
aside out of that 70 30 000 in a
separate high yield savings account
we're going to call that your emergency
fund and you never touch it even if you
have an emergency it's just sitting
there for really bad days
okay okay okay and then that leaves us
about 40 Grand doesn't it
it does yeah okay and uh we can do you
have children
I do I have three miners at home
um if anybody's going to college if
anybody's going to college you're gonna
need that 40 Grand
um I'm not sure yet they don't know yeah
they're kind of younger still so well
let's let's talk to an investment
advisor about setting that aside for
them so you got an emergency fund you're
debt free I've used up your 110 you're
going to get on a detailed budget and
you're gonna start putting 15 of your
household income away in a 401k or Roth
IRA we'll show you how to do every bit
of that Johnny if you want to do it I
can show you how to do it
um but what we're doing is is we're
going from I eat everything in sight
anytime I want to eat it and now I'm fat
and I don't want to do that anymore so
now I'm not going to eat everything in
sight and be fat because I did that I
ate every donut in a 50 mile radius
Johnny and I got fat as a hog just a
sloshing hillbilly hog it was awful and
so I had to quit eating everything in
sight because it didn't work for me you
know and I had to say okay I'm going to
actually take care of this body I only
got one and your money's the same way
you've got to make it behave you can't
be disorganized chaotic and impulsive
and end up anything but broke
and that's that's the thing so you're
not a you you really have done some very
good things in this process but uh dude
I'm getting ready to send you to boot
camp if you want to do this and you're
going to come out totally fit
and wealthy
and if I had a punk rock band
the first thing I would do in this show
is over I would call and say we're
changing our names to the sloshing
hillbilly Hogs
we would be incredible incredible well
battle of the bands names here we go I
know I mean I may have to change our
name that could happen right there the
sloshing hillbilly Hogs
didn't even know those existed did you
it's it's its own breed John yeah yeah
yeah yeah so I I think it's important to
call man
poor Johnny here was just doing what he
was told to do
I'm just doing it was told to do so buy
everybody else but everybody else normal
people I'm gonna get normal get my
points
I'm gonna save some money
I'm gonna get a big super nice you're
always going to have a car payment
and I just worked my butt off and I have
nothing
and it'll kill you man it'll feel like a
rat in a wheel